everybody's going on play here I'm here
outside our offices suite 101 this is
where I'm gonna be living for the next
20 years of my life and the officers are
not not finished yeah they're the
construction so I thought I would take a
look see how they're coming along this
is it pretty sweet pretty sweet
there's a pieces missing when they want
an exit they were gonna build an office
for the digital team a lot of outlets
here sorry I'm just gonna plug something
in you know that never happened
underneath the cord that they walked by
is a high-traffic area so really glad we
got an outlet here that's very important
one thing I like the most about our new
space is that we are very close to the
kitchen yeah fridge washing machine the
the microwave coffee pot copier fax
machine giant tangled cords pretty great
just like your kitchen at home what
weird thing also on terms like the
planning is you have the kitchen oh no
we're eating oh this is so fun Oh guys
isn't this a good meal is a great meal
okay I'm just gonna go to the bathroom
I'll be right back that's right bathroom
in the kitchen
this can't be gotta be some law against
this right so basically your food
going from here into here is basically
through view so goes who goes here
through me right into the bathroom
alright week to get in here and start
ripping stuff up there's a little one
last thing to do and that is mark my
territory
marked it see you guys later